the u.s says it's seeing the foundation
of russian cyber attacks on the u.s it's
monitoring scanning efforts essentially
hackers probing for weak spots national
security adviser jake sullivan says any
such attack on a nato member will bring
a coordinated response we could see
circumstances in which a collective
response by the alliance to a cyber
attack would be called by an ally that
is absolutely something where we and
other countries could bring capabilities
to bear to help a country both defend
itself and respond to a particular cyber
attack now that's not necessarily the
same thing as a military response that
response could take many different forms
when presidents biden and putin met in
geneva last year the u.s president said
key areas of infrastructure should be
off limits to cyber attack that was in
response to the 2020 solar winds attack
federal servers were hit 30 000 private
companies and public organizations
impacted washington says the russian
foreign intelligence service was behind
that hack and addressing business
leaders on monday joe biden warned them
to get ready the magnitude of russia's
cyber capacity is fairly consequential
and it's coming the federal government
is doing its part to get ready
but let me be absolutely clear about
something it's not just in your interest
or at stake whether potential use of
cyber security
it is the national interest of stake the
russian government denies its planning
cyber attacks saying it would not resort
to what it calls banditry
but officials here believe it's a way
for russia to strike back at the u.s for
providing weapons to ukraine without
escalating the actual fighting
alan fisher al-jazeera at the white
house